Speaker 1: On what is quickly becoming an
historic day or a historic day, depending
on your grammatical preference, it's great
to be joined by Bill Share, who's a contributor
to the Washington Monthly Real Clear Politics
Politico.
Bill, you know, let's not immediately include
the Ukraine Russia situation in our conversation
and sort of start with like, if this weren't
going on, what would your thoughts have been
on where the 2022 midterms seem to be looking
in terms of who is going to control the House
and Senate after November and then maybe will
integrate the question about Russia, Ukraine?
Speaker 3: Well, you know, in one respect,
you would say things don't look good for Democrats.
Obviously, any time the president's party
is facing midterm, it tends to not go great.
We've had thirty six midterms since the Civil
War, and the president's party loses house
seats in 33 of those 36.
Now, of course, a lot of times they lose control
of Congress because the margins are bigger,
but now the margin is five.
So even the slightest loss you risk losing
control.
And if Biden's at the same job approval in
November as he is today, which is about 42
percent, that's not going to be a good midterm.
Having said that, there are those three exceptions.
And there's also a fourth exception where
the Democrats, where Democrats lost less than
five seats, that was 1962.
So those four exceptions are 1934, 1962, 1998,
2002.
So what's what's the thread in those exceptions?
Thirty four is FDR his first term he's tackling
the Great Depression 62 Cuban Missile Crisis
is solved ten days before the midterm 1998.
Republicans are moving towards impeaching
Bill Clinton, and there's a lot of talk in
the era of constitutional crisis and 2002.
We're still in the shadow of of nine 911 crisis
is is the thread of those four exceptions.
If you're in the president's party and there's
a crisis and you're seen as handling that
crisis well, right, you can beat those odds
right now.
As it stands today, we have not counting Ukraine
two big crises that are intertwined the pandemic
and inflation.
Today, Biden is not seen as handling those
well, so that's not becoming a plus.
It is certainly possible that by November,
the pandemic is going to look a lot better
and inflation is going to look a lot better.
We can't say for certain today it has definitely
already winding down, and we just don't know
if one of the new variants are going to kick
up between now and then.
It's going to throw us for another loop.
But and Ukraine is a third crisis.
And again, I'm not.
It's hardly one.
Can I glibly say, Oh, Biden is going to take
care of this fantastically?
It's a very, very complicated problem.
And even the most fantastic president.
Might I handle it in the most perfect of ways?
Speaker 1: But to add to that bill, I mean,
no matter what Biden does, Republicans will
blame him.
I mean, they're already doing it.
Last night, Trump with Laura Ingraham saying
the problem here is Biden and the rigged election
and people coming over to the US-Mexico border
that he said that's the cause of what's happening
in Russia, Ukraine.
You have a bunch of people already saying
he it's his fault and to some degree, that
may stick, at least in some voters minds.
Speaker 3: Well, let's not completely assume
that it's going to be the unanimous Republican
message that Biden is a weak leader and this
is all this false.
No, it's just out there push by Trump.
And I believe it is argue that there's a better
than even odds.
The Republicans won't do that very well.
Good.
But there is division in the Republican Party
on a number of fronts, and certainly Ukraine
is one of those those issues and policy versus
Russia's one of those issues.
One thing I think could help Biden and Democrats,
you know, both the Ukraine and beyond is to
play up bipartisanship.
The reason why the president's party usually
does poorly in midterms is you get a pendulum
swing because the governing party has to govern.
Governing is difficult.
You have to make compromises.
You have to.
You can't deliver on everything that your
base wants to see in the platform.
Unexpected crises occur.
All these things put stress on a diverse governing
coalition, and the opposition can put aside
their differences and just focus on how much.
They hate you.
That's the normal order of midterm business,
but we already have secured some bipartisan
victories, the biggest one being the infrastructure
bill.
There are some smaller ones along with that.
And this is done with the help of Mitch McConnell,
which has made Donald Trump very mad.
Donald Trump actively attacks Mitch McConnell
for helping Biden.
Yeah.
And we've seen Biden give conflicting messages
on this score.
Sometimes he wants to say, Oh, we would do
a lot better at these.
Republicans weren't obstructing us.
And sometimes, he says, we're making Washington
work and getting things done.
And I would lean more towards that latter
message than the former because what it shows
you are getting things done, electing us has
been good for you.
We've done some good things.
If things aren't perfect in the universe and
it drives wedges through the opposition.
So you want you want to unify yourself and
divide the other guys.
Right.
And if Biden can do things with Ukraine that
pull in the more hawkish anti-Putin types
in the Republican Party, the Lindsey Graham's
the Marco Rubio is the Mitch McConnell's.
If it can make it uncomfortable for them to
side with Trump, that's going to further help
reverse the normal trajectory of a midterm.
Speaker 1: I can't help but think that if
the last four days were not what they have
been with Ukraine, Russia, there would be
many discussions, like the ones my audience
was having prior to that point.
Like, for example, if Biden can only forgive
some student loans between now and November,
if Biden can decriminalize cannabis federally
between now and over these types of things,
which it quite frankly doesn't seem Biden
has any interest at all in doing many in my
audience feel very strongly that that would
have a significant impact on the outcome of
the midterms.
What do you think about that?
Speaker 3: Well, I mean, you got to do two
things.
I mean, unifying the party and splitting opposition
requires two things you've got to do something
to energize your own base.
Yes.
And you got to don't take your eye off the
swing.
The swing still exists.
Doing both those things is complicated and
there's inherent tensions there.
I don't know if do it what you suggest, which
are executive order things which may go beyond
what Biden thinks is actually constitutional
or legal and would be I'm probably subject
to litigation that might not be in Biden's
comfort zone.
I do think it would be greatly helpful to
get some significant piece of what was called
build back better past to let the progressive
base know, Hey, this was this wasn't a waste
of your time getting us elected.
We've done some things that are significant,
significant here right now.
The progressive base is feeling that they've
gotten the short end of the stick, and I understand
that.
And I do think you've got to give them something.
And so I see folks more inclined to think
about what can I do?
What can Biden do by himself because I don't
trust Joe Manchin or consider him to do anything
helpful.
But whatever it is, I think it needs to be
something that can get done and will stick.
Yes.
So that progressive base feels like they got
something out of this.
Speaker 1: Part of why, as you laid out, it's
not looking great for Democrats in November.
Are these historical realities that you laid
out very clearly regarding the 36 midterms
since the Civil War?
The other part of it that I very strongly
paying attention to is that it doesn't really
seem Democrats are doing anything particularly
helpful to themselves in many ways.
And so I'm sort of looking for help from Republicans
in hurting themselves.
And one of the things I'm looking at that
I think is probably OK for Democrats is this
sort of civil war aspect of what's going on
in the Republican Party.
You've got it used to be just pro and anti-Trump,
but now you've got the never Trump, the pro-Trump
and the formerly pro-Trump, which are increasingly
sort of making some noise, it seems to me,
absent any great strategy from Democrats.
I welcome that sort of infighting.
And it sounds like you're saying in general,
division on the opposite side is a good thing.
Speaker 3: Oh, absolutely.
And there are certainly things that could
happen with Trump's very aggressive involvement
in Republican primaries.
It's going to be hurtful to Republicans, and
we can't know, you know, it's possible Trump
backs a lunatic and that lunatic wins the
primary and wins the general election, which
is not good.
But we have examples in the very recent past
where Republicans have nominated people that
threw away winnable seats.
You know, Christine O'Donnell in Delaware,
Todd Akin in Missouri, Richard Mourdock in
Indiana.
You know, this is all pre Trump and Trump's
not getting very involved in all sorts of
races, Senate and House and governor.
You know, one of the big, you know, difficult
races for Democrats is going to be Georgia,
where Raphael Warnock is holding on.
To see very tenuously.
And you got Trump pushing Herschel Walker,
who's got a whole litany of scandals in his
past.
Yeah, and encouraging a bloody political civil
war between Brian Kemp and David Perdue.
So and there's a book coming out called Flip
by Great Blue saying it's not quite out yet.
I just I guess it's it hasn't been published
yet, but I just wrote a book review of it.
So it's on my mind.
I mean, the things that Republicans did in
Georgia in the run up to 2020 are just comically
ridiculous and self-defeating.
And, you know, Democrats do a lot of things
right.
Republicans did a lot of things wrong, and
Democrats just barely won those races.
So it's very possible that Trump's going to
lead Republicans at a very bad path and throw
away opportunities for them.
Speaker 1: And at this point, the disc, specifically
the discussions of the election was stolen.
Who does that help and hurt in your calculation?
Speaker 3: I mean, look at the look at Georgia
that hurt Republicans in Georgia in 2020 for
the runoffs.
Yeah, we know that turnout went down in very
red conservative rural areas, particularly
in the place where Trump held rallies between
the November election, the January runoff.
So I don't know if that will replicate in
2022, but that is a risk for Republicans.
If they if Trump poisons the well and tells
folks that things are still rigged, that could
hurt them.
Now, another issue with 2020 is who's going
to win the Secretary of state primaries?
How many secretary of state races are these
issues going to be front and center and how
does that impact turnout?
Are they going to get pushed above the fold
and be more prominent?
Do they unify the Trumpian right and energize
their base?
Or do they alienate those?
I mean, like, like in Georgia, there was white,
college educated Romney type voters that were
appalled by what Trump was doing, and they
moved to the Democrats.
Yeah.
So there is that risk for Republicans there
as well
Speaker 1: in terms of some of the factions
on the left.
You know, for a while, there's been pejoratively
they're called tank is, I think, a less pejorative
term as the revolutionary left.
And you know, they're kind of like Nicolas
Maduro is good and cool.
And Castro, Cuba, it's cool.
And they were sort of like pro-Putin.
But there's now this other faction that I
called the alt left like, for example, Glenn
Greenwald and Tulsi Gabbard.
They're not revolutionary left, but they certainly
seem to be this alt left thing.
They were saying Putin's not going to invade
all this stuff.
Are these factions?
How sizable do you think these factions are
in terms of the people that actually vote?
And the reason I ask it that way is in the
2020 Democratic primary, if you looked on
Reddit and Twitter, you would have dramatically
overestimated the level of support for someone
like Bernie.
But when it came to voting in the primary,
that was not where the Democratic Party was
at the time.
So like, how big do you think these factions
are?
Speaker 3: Well, I mean, I think the Bernie
faction is a whole lot bigger than the Tulsi
faction.
Oh, absolutely.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt, without a doubt.
Speaker 3: I mean, I think Greenwald has really
discredited himself among much of the left,
like he's really what he has held on to is,
you know, Tulsi left, which is which is a
splinter.
Yeah.
You know, he's mostly celebrate on the right
these days and the left.
So I mean, there is this sort of horseshoe,
you know, dynamic where there are people who
have this kind of mix of mixture positions
and they're generally, you know, anti deep
state anti American establishment, anti-military
industrial complex established that they lump
a lot of things into that that rubric to the
point where they go as far as they as Greenwald.
But apparently he's arguing that this isn't
really an invasion, that America brought this
on because I mean, there's a there's a jack
of an article saying, Well, that's a little
not as commentary to Putin as some others,
but saying, Well, it's not.
It's not all Putin's fault because we wouldn't
do the compromise where we say Ukraine can't
be a Naito.
And I understand there's are certainly times
in life.
We do some strategic ambiguity to avoid conflict.
Yeah, but it's pretty clear that Ukraine has
good reason to be in know because Britain
is hell bent on occupying that.
They want that protection so they don't get
obliterated.
And so it's hard for me to take that off the
equate out of the equation when looking at
the situation.
So I mean that those voices are out there.
They're certainly easier to hear in social
media because they're loud, right?
But as far as their impact electorally, I
think it's very small.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And it seems the effect is more getting those
people to stay home because it's sort of like
in the 2016, the alt left in 2016 often seem
to argue it's kind of irrelevant, whether
it's Trump or Hillary.
And to me, it seemed less about it turned
votes from Hillary to Trump than it just made
some people stay home who probably would have.
Voted for Hillary.
Speaker 3: Yeah, and and we didn't have that
in 2020.
I mean, people were angry enough for Trump
that whatever their idiosyncratic foreign
policy views were or whatever their concerns
about how moderate Biden would be that became
secondary to stopping Trump.
Right.
The classic how you put aside our differences
and unify around the common enemy and look
dealing with Ukraine.
It's not going to be necessarily easy to unite
a broad swath of America around whatever policy
we adopt, because particularly if we're doing
something that is somewhat aggressive and
you know, no one's talking about, you know,
troops on the ground, of course.
But even even economic sanctions could get
blowback where Russia does economic things.
The odds are cyberattacks on us and creates
disruption and discomfort within America.
It's not a given that the average American
is going to appreciate that and believe that
this is worth the sacrifice that we're doing.
It's going to take rhetorical effort on.
The part of this is where bipartisanship would
help.
You know, as much as you and I might really
think Marco Rubio is appalling.
Lindsey Graham was appalling just as a matter
of politics.
If Biden is saying, we got to take these these
actions to check Putin and it's going to mean
some hurt at the pump, it's going to mean
some complications with our cyber infrastructure.
We're going do our best to counter it.
But you got to expect it's going to be hard
sometimes if a Rubio and a Graham a giving
Biden coverage, saying he's doing the right
thing, that's going to mitigate the ability
for those on like alt left types who are going
to or Tucker Carlson types are going to push
into the media bloodstream.
Why are we doing this?
Biden is making you pay five dollars the pump
for what you create.
Why should you care about that?
People on the fringes are going to push that
argument, and it's argue that can have some
traction.
Yeah, so so in that respect, they're relevant
players if they're not necessarily electorally
large.
And the more diverse cover Biden has for whatever
actions he takes, the better he's going to
be able to withstand that and try to get the
American people on his side.
Speaker 1: Well, the next five days, both
in terms of what happens in Ukraine, Russia
and then up to and including what Biden chooses
to say at a State of the Union address, they're
definitely going to be worth worth following.
We've been speaking with Bill Share contributor
to the Washington Monthly Real Clear